c'est un discours très puissant et il
parle comme une personne banale pas
comme un président puis il parle pour
tous les Ukrainiens il traduit
exactement ce que l'on pense
exactement
c'était un moment important historique
même notre président est allé jusqu'aux
États-Unis pour parler au président
américain
je pense que notre président est le
meilleur que l'on ait eu ces dernières
années c'était incroyable d'avoir autant
de soutien du Congrès américain
il a été applaudi très longuement ça
montre à quel point il est respecté
ces derniers jours nous avons eu de
l'eau et de l'électricité pour seulement
deux heures par jour je pense que ces
missiles peuvent changer la donne sur le
terrain le seul problème c'est qu'on a
besoin de plus l'Ukraine est un grand
pays